with the stroke of a pen Russia defied
protesters in Kiev minorities in Crimea
and leaders across the Western world the
audience gave a standing ovation just
before the signing ceremony both
chambers of Parliament met in the
Kremlin to hear Vladimir Putin's vision
for the future of Crimea he used the
speech as another opportunity to justify
Russia's actions in Crimea and he
highlighted the region's history and
mutual importance to Moscow is about
Sevastopol a legendary City the city of
great destiny the city of fortresses and
the Russian Black Sea Fleet his message
soon turned into an indictment of the
West
NATO's eastward expansion its
involvement in Libya and the conflict in
former Yugoslavia time and again Putin
said the West has forced confrontation
with Russia in the case of Ukraine our
Western partners have crossed a red line
in this instance Russia has legitimate
interests that must be recognized which
he praised the Ukrainian soldiers in
Crimea for not turning the dispute into
an armed conflict the Kremlin does not
recognize the new government in Kiev but
protean said Russia's relations with
Ukraine are extremely important and
would remain so we don't want to break
up at Ukraine but Crimea will remain
Russian Crimea is Russia's most
strategically important factor in the
region after signing the treaty poutine
greeted supporters in Moscow's Red
Square saying Crimea was returning home
the Kremlin says the treaty comes into
effect immediately but it lays out a
period until the end of the year to
formalize the annexation of Crimea
you